all right we're good this is a podcast
you know chris d'elia he starts he
always calls his audience babies baby
like okay baby let's talk I only watched
his clips make sure to subscribe from
this to this podcast and then
unsubscribe and subscribe again so we
climb up the charts
yes we're climbing we were top 50 a few
days ago when I checked top 65 and then
we were creeping to 55 so I saw some
good movement there it's like the movies
where there it's like a band it's like
climbing up the Billboard charts and
they show like exactly number one the
clips that we're posting on our social
they're not getting as much traction as
I wish traction like what are your views
or comments or well I only care about
views and comments in order to get more
podcast right listeners yeah so I guess
there you would need people essentially
tagging their friends or you'd need to
start showing up and discover yeah and
it's so starting I also have noticed
that when I I have a smaller following
than our branded channels but when I
share something it gets way more
engagement than a brand so yeah people
like following people and listen to
people more I also don't ever share it
so I should share it to that big nine
thousand Twitter followers I got and you
have five more me you have five hundred
more than me but I'm gonna beat you in
the next four days I think I also bought
five thousand a long time ago me too
they degraded they like go away cuz
Twitter like bans the accounts but when
I bought the five thousand I got way
more followers per day same because
people wanted to follow somebody who
already has so I'm a virgin two hundred
new people a day and I'm enjoying it
I don't even check all right what do we
got I want to talk to about talk about
this idea
Simon IDs a company arsenic yeah they've
been around for about four years now
yeah I know I don't know how they're
doing do you know if they're doing well
they were doing okay
basically the way that I knew some like
media people who talked about them and
knew them and I'm almost positive that
it's run like it looks like it's run
which is a bunch of kids who are
good-looking and rich the mansion and
they just dude right so debauchery and
so the idea is arsenic is essentially
playboy for the snapchat generation and
they have a snapchat channel because you
know the idea is like okay playboys big
deal
what would playboy be like today it
would not be a magazine it would be you
know a snapchat channel and so they
created the snapchat channel which is
perfect cuz it's like if you follow it
you get it if not it's not in your face
so it's not like like Facebook would be
a little weird
Instagram would be a little weird and
they have email too and they just have
this mansion and they have all these
models and it's not porn but it's
definitely models we're good looking and
they just have one model like sort of
take over the channel least is what it
was three years ago I just think there's
a great idea they raised three million
bucks I don't know how they're doing so
they've got books they do like tours I
think that it could be doing a the ideas
cool it's a cash cow I think hmm
well I because they were getting
millions of views back van on their
videos I can only assume it's grown
unless snapchat blocked them but they're
not outside the bounds of what snapchat
allows porn right no they don't allow
porn but the unity allowed nudity they
don't if you're putting on your stories
you'll get banned eventually if you're
doing me what if you have a private they
do they don't do nudity
what up for a private account you can
eventually if it gets flagged they'll
take it down like they're not in the
rules to do nude well that's fine have
you heard of only fans yeah love it so
explain only fans only fan so basically
what happened is on snapchat all these
porn stars were putting up like porn
yeah like what softcore porn I don't
think it was like sex but like pay me
ten dollars and I'll let you follow me
right and you all all of my account
where I post nudes and only fans
launched and what they did was it was a
platform where they I don't think they
started with porn but now it is that
yeah so just embrace it but basically if
you I don't even think it's porn I think
it's like web girls like webcam girls
and you pay twenty dollars however much
they want you to and you get access to
their private video feeds yeah it's like
patreon but porn based yeah so you pay
you become a contributor and then you
get their private photos and videos it's
taken off has it yeah and the reason
yeah cuz I was doing like who cares if I
consume it or not from a business point
of view that's how I know about it we
all care and I mean no surprising so I
did yeah but so here's you know why I
think these things take
office the people who don't take care of
the creators they they they for these
types of things they they go away yes
and so there's always demand so the
demand is always there the question is
does the platform allow the supply to do
what they want to do and the big
platforms don't do it coz not worth
their brand and risk and all the stuff
because but only fans I for sure but I
would bet you for sure there in north of
a hundred million in subscription
revenue and then they take their cut
that's insane at one point in time well
we had a we had blab like live streaming
product and it wasn't working we had to
pivot and we pivoted adventure to video
gaming but I definitely laid out a case
to the company that investor I was like
look porn is the porn is where that
horse would be the bats like these
they're not [__] on camera I don't
think okay well whatever you want to
call it like softcore porn or whatever
but like going after the sort of the cam
girl market is a pretty it's a big
market and the websites that are there
really really suck and so so I was like
you answered well we had kind of a
heart-to-heart we're like is this what
we want to build and my co-founder felt
a certain way the investors felt a
certain way like did FERC on want to do
um he was like not down to that I'm so
done with that yeah so I think it's you
got to make a personal choice then I've
had a bunch of entrepreneurs reach out
being like hey we saw you did blab we
read your post mortem you guys got to 4
million users but it didn't work I have
a very similar concept I think it's
gonna work can you give me some advice I
tell them from the bat jump I'm like
this version is not gonna work consider
porn I think it could work
consider the cam girl angle because you
know that's the one stone we didn't turn
when we were considering you know where
to pivot this thing to make it I would
for sure do that because thick all these
like patreon all the [__] they're like
we're gonna empower creators okay I'm
behind that but even though a lot of
times I think they don't but if you're
gonna empower creator imagine this like
woman who can just crush it by not
breaking the law and just using her own
body
I'm philosophically I'm so in favor of
that right yeah I think as a business
person I'm definitely in favor of it I
think it's just a portion this person I
love it as just like a human being I'm
like yeah so you want to their body turn
little ideas or trends off this so one
there's this fund called vice ventures
that is basically investing and we've
covered in trends that other investors
won't invest in because like investors
typically if you're a VC your investors
they're called LPS they are typically
not just like rich individuals they're
institutions so it'll be like a pension
fund for firefighters in New York or
this you know the school endowment will
give you 20 members and so you can so
they won't want their money going into
certain types of companies this is why
cannabis investments started to take off
because only alternative investors
investors you've had a little more
freedom were able to go into them big
investors knew they were good spaces but
they weren't able to move on it as
quickly because they had to worry about
their help ease so five spenders came
out and they were like look you know sex
drugs alcohol whatever rightly they're
basically like taking sort of this the
seven sins and they were like we
specifically look for companies that are
doing businesses in this in these areas
and we'll invest in them and I think
it's a very I think it's a if you're
gonna do a venture fund you could either
just make another cookie cutter hey
we're a seed fund come to us instead of
all these other guys or you take a focus
and build a brand around being different
and I think it was a very very smart
approach I like it Ivan but I invested
in this company called Lucy yeah it's a
nicotine replacement there
it's basically nicorette gum we got to
get wasn't I'm Dave Dave we have to get
him on because when I met him for the
first time through you after hustle con
he spit off seven ideas and when we were
just standing there talking and I was
like I'd ask for one and he gave me like
a dope idea and I was like you got more
of those he goes yeah I got a list and
he started reading off his ideas and
they were fantastic so you might be
listening we got to get him on the on
the couch to hear of a quick porn story
yeah okay so I worked out of this all
like I were given nod of approval I
worked out of this office called the
founders dojo and it was the greatest
thing ever
I'll tell another story about it but
basically it was if you've seen the TV
show Silicon Valley it was we had Erlich
Bachman it was an Erlich Bachman type of
guy named Dave who was a great guy but
totally inappropriate and disgusting in
a good way and the office was filthy and
there was this guy I forget his name
ritesh and Chris yeah and I remember and
it was this this little skinny Indian
guy and he was
crazy and awesome and he was like the
stereotypical Silicon Valley hacker
where he could get a job at any big
company and make $200,000 a year but
he's like no [__] that I'm like nah I'm
[__] the corporate pigs right and so
he would sleep at that office and Dave
would buy him pizza all the time because
he was like get one to be poor and do
this thing and so he created a app or
know a site website that would crawl
tumblr no I think all the internet okay
for the fascists for the gifs that had
the highest velocity of growth and so if
a Jif launched popular gifs he would
tell you right away
which one's gonna be the most popular
and then you would see it on the screen
and it was called the worst drug the
worst drug dot TV it's not there anymore
and that sounds like a silly thing but
that's not why he did it he did it
because what he was trying to do was a
find the fastest like technology that
could find the fast growing stuff and if
you would go to the worst drug at Tom
you could type in something like dog and
the search feature would autofill like
wicked fast like way faster and then you
would click enter and it would be BAM a
high-def Jeff there's a high death it
was full screen and it was all screens
laser fast so the technology is very
like Pied Piper like the technology
wasn't like whatever pop Piper did it
was the fact that it was all behind
these scenes like a bunch of nerds being
like yeah our gifs load the fastest and
like look it's like HD and it happened
in nanoseconds and he would spend nights
and I would come back and would be just
a tiny improvement but we don't gather
on it well so here's the cut this the
the point of the story turns out the
most popular gifs on the Internet 99% of
them are super hardcore raunchy porn
like real raunchy porn and so because
when I went to the site it was all porn
there wasn't like porn and then some
basketball gym it was only porn I was
like this is a porn site and so at the
opposite the dojo we would have these
huge screens of it like his workstation
and the way that he sat was everyone
could see it and we kind of got immune
to it but it was like the raw chia
should ever and we would he'd like guys
check this out early in the morning we
would come in 11 a of it which was early
and he'd be rubbing his eyes and [__]
and he'd be like check this out and all
eight of us would grab around this high
def screen and be like and he would type
in the word like
like facial and like like watch how
fastest loads and we were just so immune
we're like looking at the convert that
were like oh yeah wow you could like see
the shine in the liquid like it was like
it was so funny and we would have like
these like lawyers come into the office
and people who were actually are like
investors who were trying to raise money
for the other companies and we would
forget that this was on the big screen
what happened this was like what's this
guy doing now the site the worst drug
got millions of millions of millions of
visitors the engagement was stupidly
like good
he couldn't monetize it they couldn't
use it so there were so many
restrictions no ad network or a lot him
to use it and so even though the site I
think it was getting at least for sure
millions I think maybe tens of millions
of monthly uniques and it made zero
money it only cost him a lot of money
and the story ends with like someone in
Bulgaria are laughs eeeh like this like
Communists X communist country wanted to
buy the site and it was all weird they
flew him out there and he's like wait
these guys are like mobsters and they
ended up like bailing and they just shut
it down because it was guys what do now
he works at Facebook yeah but I've never
seen him oh my skateboard I had a
skateboard and left at the office he
stole it and I've never seen a getaway
dude I've never seen it you needed
transferred ROG that's his name ROG I've
never seen ROG because that guy is gonna
build something amazing or it's gonna be
a very sad ending but either way it's
gonna be not average not to use yeah he
was he was like if you think of like
this idea of what Silicon Valley is that
was that right Wow
okay that's incredible I like that story
you were talking about okay we were talk
about our snake real quick quick idea so
what they're doing is the playboy on
snapchat if that's working and I don't
know if it's working so go look into it
but if it is working in a big way I
don't think that there's just gonna be
one of those so like in the same way
that there's all these porn brands right
there's like girls gone wild it focuses
on college-age things somebody out there
could create arsenic for college or for
different like whatever genre and so I
just like this desert if I are that arse
arsenic is not porn modeling
scanty modeling more like playboy and
Maxim current Playboy exactly so you
could build playboy but of other genres
and just or you could just literally
clone them and I think it would be very
low cost and I think you would be able
to do a lot of you be able to drive a
lot of views and I ultimately get a lot
of sponsorships in the same way that
maximum Playboy were able to make pretty
big businesses out of what they do now
they had subscriptions so I don't know
if you would do subscriptions maybe you
use only fans I'm not sure but we should
figure it out yeah I I'm gonna look up
the old new fan I'm interested in this
uh III I have a lot of ideas I'm gonna
come back a little more prepared on this
because I think there is something there
what else you got okay so you have HQ HQ
died obviously yeah I thought like it
could have been cool I'm like they could
be like jeopardy
jeopardy is huge so if you don't know
what HQ was it was a mobile app it was a
game show like Wheel Fortune jeopardy
whatever but that was all done on a
mobile app which was when I saw this
product some our friend Eric who does
tribe socks he showed me this happen he
was like dude my friend went to go work
at this company it's really interesting
check this out he pulls it up so at 6:00
p.m. every day they would do the game
show so you get a notification at 6:00
you open the app there's a host a live
got you know live live game show host on
live streaming and he would ask trivia
questions that you would push the button
and you have ten seconds to answer you
push the button real quick to answer if
you got all ten or twelve questions
right
you'd win the prize at the end which at
that time it was there was 400 players
and the prize was like $500 this thing
grew like crazy they had games with over
a million concurrent player I said
except I was like a million and a half
and exactly over a million players and
over I believe they had over a million
dollars in prize money over time and so
this thing had this run and they got
tons of funding founders fund funded
that ten million dollars of funding a
hundred million dollar valuation and
then they had big-time brands launch
stuff on there so they were like you
know this game is sponsored by Nike it's
all trivia about athletes and we're
gonna drop this shoe the new shoe
release is happening live on HQ and
that's the prize they were doing some
interesting stuff but it was kind of a
fad and which everyone knew which
everyone knew because it was like games
all have this hype cycle and then this
decline of
they're not games aren't super super
sticky most of them and this was
definitely that so this big novelty grew
like crazy viral product in many ways as
somebody makes products it's very
inspiring because it was like so simple
yet so awesome and I actually felt like
product there I'm not trying to be
hyperbolic but I felt like there was
some revolutionary things for sure it
was like oh I'm looking at the future
this is this is what the future looks
like I still think that's what the
future looks like HQ dot for many
reasons
socata founders are sucking literally
one founder died he overdosed on drugs
the other founders they were sort of
always infighting they were both sort of
like kind of come across at least from
the outside a sort of like moody artists
yeah one of them I believe started fine
also Russ yeah yeah both of them they
were both the founders of fine so
definitely sort of brilliant guys in a
way but everyone says that Russ is a
dick yeah in the and he and he got
removed a CEO because he had some
problems you know he was a dick or
whatever the other guy got removed also
never figured it out and the the game
show host Scott became this kind of like
cult sensation because he was the host
everyone saw him every day and he
tweeted out when it shut down recently
he was just like this company died for
one reason alone and that's the sort of
incompetence and arrogance of the
founders and I was like yeah damn that
is like you don't usually hear that like
everybody's so PC and always just
worried about the career well he's a
comedian he ain't give a [__] yeah he
definitely did not give a [__] because
that was that's pretty brutal on the
day's shut down let's say can I tell you
what I would do
yes okay so I would I have no idea if
they did this not I would have built
this knowing that it's gonna die and so
it's like it's my thing is I'm gonna be
a hit machine right and I'm gonna use
this formula and I always thought about
this with remember like cronut yeah okay
you know how like these viral food
things like these food things go viral I
like one day sat down I'm like what
makes them go viral so it's and I've
like broke it down to a handful of
categories which is like it's either of
it's gotta be a food that's typically
aside but you're gonna eat it in excess
so for example only cookie dough instead
of so ice cream that's just cookie done
right or to make this ah you make the
topping domain yep
so like one formula you could use yep
like or like fondue so likes fondue is
typically an appetizer
fondue only right another thing is you
take the shape of it and you make it a
ridiculous shape yes
easy including small to big like there's
Bob's doughnut and there's my neck which
is rising so you make something small
big big small right the the fifth or
fourth thing is color rainbow Raggles so
you just take the color green ketchup
Instagram a bowl yes yes and then I had
a fifth one which was some mashups which
is cronut right oh yeah and then and
then that was the fifth one you take
there Doritos locos taco one of them the
most successful fast-food thing in like
the last ten years was this Dorito locos
taco and then every fast-food chain
hired these agencies to be like find me
the next Doritos right and so those are
the five like categories that I
discovered and then it's like okay so
you just make it go viral by you you
have to have distribution via Thrillist
BuzzFeed and then eventually it's like
we just have your own handle and then
you're gonna like these okay and then
you're gonna have a small shop outside
outside in Brooklyn or in Manhattan and
you're just gonna you're always putting
out bangers yeah you're just gonna
[__] knock it out the park and you're
gonna have a line all the time and then
three months later boom that one shut
down switch now we're doing cookie dough
ice cream every season you come out with
a new one viral sensation yeah it's like
all right now we're doing - we're doing
rainbow cake now or green ketchup and
hot dogs like you just like you use like
okay it's so if I was I've always
thought about like that's the way to go
you just have a small you just a bang
and you're banging these out and then
for the ones that last in our hits like
Crona it might be a hit I mean that's
kind of like its own category now then
you've that's like you're one of your
tempo franchises it's always available
yeah that's what I would do and then so
with HQ trivia I would have on the same
thing this is like supreme for food it's
like you have this limited scarce kind
of like out there thing what you're
doing is you're making these these sort
of wild concoctions on the food side
using these five different yeah but it's
all for maleic yes it's just like one of
these five form is Zynga and then you do
a limited edition drop you basically say
you know you tweet out at 1:00 a.m. it's
live you get a huge line people cover
the fact that there's a line and then it
becomes a thing in the hipster town yeah
this is so easy like Bagel Bites like
pizza and bagels this is
wit back when you were doing your hotdog
stand if you knew everything you know
now but you still needed to do hot dogs
in you would end up doing something more
like this like green ketchup like that
are my stick to catch up with only be
green right and what I did back then was
I had a what I did was like you just
have a little shtick like mine was my
onions I would boil them in coca-cola
which a lot of people do I would just
tell everyone I did that right and so
there's this is actually a famous
copywriting trick which is have you ever
heard of um Oh a time like a watch like
a like a wristwatch being described as
like with quartz movement yes they all
have [__] quartz movement right they
all do all of them do or like space-age
aluminum they all that's not even a
thing first of all like what's that
madmen line it's like our filters are
rolled or something like yeah and
they're like well everyone says and
they're like well they don't know it
right so space-age aluminum that that
means nothing first of all all lumen
right first of all nonsense yeah
and second of all quartz movement every
single watch has that right and so the
idea here is you just take something
that they don't know even though all the
insiders know you just tell them right
we did this experiment when we were
doing the sushi restaurant where we took
the descriptions of our food so it'd be
like you know you take a Philadelphia
role which is like this Americanized
it's salmon it's cream cheese and it's
cucumber in a sushi roll and then we
would just so Dan Ariely was one of our
advisers and he's the guy wrote
particular as well and so he would he
told us like hey one of the reasons wine
charges this premium is cuz they created
a whole language around what they do you
need to create a language around sushi
so that people who start to learn about
it feel like they know more and now they
want to pay more so they can have the
better thing just teach of what is the
better thing and so we would you know we
started just adding words as one
experiment we would have one version of
our website where it was all online
ordering so is one version of our
website would be the normal website then
our a B test was the other variation was
our Philadelphia roll would be called
like we called the Philadelphia roll and
then the description would be like
Atlantic fresh you know never frozen
salmon with you know Philadelphia
Delphia cream cheese and a finely sliced
cucumber and we would raise the price
and we would get like more orders even
despite the higher price that's crazy
and and so this is like a psychological
thing around yeah that [__] works
yeah
around the descriptions around things
okay back to a to you for a second so
they did try to release other games they
came out with like a word scramble type
game I think they kind of ran out of
time and also they had built the hype
too much and lesson to be learned when
you build this much hype if you start to
fail you death spiral way faster cuz the
high pressure of your expectations and
hype will crush you well so that's what
I mean is I would have built this
company exacting that like we discussed
that claw game and they're like well
they're building it so it they're gonna
just capture all the value upfront and
then let it die right so if you were to
built that right alike built that into
it it would have been it could have been
a company kind of like I imagine saying
it does this which is they just have
like they're like alright this game is
only in the last 80 days maybe right so
two quick ideas on this HQ thing so HQ
died okay you know rest in peace but two
things I could do if you wanted to make
make use of this of the insights that
were found in this I think you can do
this on top of twitch or YouTube or any
live streaming platform that already has
audience so you don't need to be your
own app you should just host create a
channel that's hosting a show and give
away the prize money and promote it in
the same way and so I think somebody
could build this on top of one of the
existing platforms not enough to build
your own tech and not have to acquire
downloads of your app which is really
expensive and I think if you just did
this every day at 7:00 p.m. on Twitch I
think a bunch of people would turn in
second idea around this is maybe the HQ
format which is this live video
streaming with this charismatic post and
question and answer could be used in
education and so I would love to see
somebody create an after school game
that parents actually pay $3 a week to
subscribe to where your kid learned
science through some Bill Nye the
Science Guy type of host and it's trivia
it's interactive and they get sort of
points as they I thought about starting
that company but I really think that
that could work I think it might also
have the sort of fade in interest but I
remember as a kid I love brain quest and
I played all these like learning games
and they were great and so I think this
is a modern-day but that's interesting
that is quite sticky I think that as we
get older I mean your kids not old
enough so you'll imagine you'll learn
this once she gets old enough but these
things that we use is we are kids were
just huge yes huge I'm into that and you
wouldn't need tens of millions of people
because you're not advertising you'd be
on subscription because parents would be
like oh I don't have to go drop my kid
off at tutoring and I don't have to like
learn this myself my kid already wants
to sit in front of the iPad all day so
okay here's an iPad game that I feel
good about because you're learning it's
kind of cool because it's live and
interactive and I could play with you
and I'll pay three bucks a week for that
do you want to hear what I've been in
that same category that I'll come back
with some more research but I was just
surfing around and saw is that but for
allowance okay tell me more so a friend
Ramones kid had I was like I was like
hey Victor does your dad give you
allowance like he better be giving you
some money right and he goes yeah but
it's all on this app but I was like what
do you mean he's like well it is
automated and I get $10 a week if I do
everything and I have a list of
everything I got to do and then it just
sends me this $10 but it sends it into
an account and I could use those on the
the places that he's already approved
that I could spend it on or if he wants
I can get this debit card that it only
works at a handful of places that's a
great idea
yeah I was like of course that's
obviously that's a horse idea yeah I get
mad at myself for not thinking of it so
I'm gonna go I haven't thought I haven't
seen their financials or any doesn't I'm
going to yeah when he told me that I was
like oh okay obviously great right what
else we got
let's do rocket this let's do um
let's get mood and then we'll just go
down the list like what do you wanna
keep going wait what's this rocket ship
thing you want my dad or skip it will do
that the end okay
Do It Yourself perfume so on trends we
released this on Tuesday two things
we're interesting that our guys found
more Steph and our guy so men and women
found which we only have two people so
uh so you're a guy and gal found that
two things I'm like thinking about all
of it first everyone talks about
meditation being like the most popular
like being a huge trend right now people
searching for sleep is actually
significantly more likes like sleep
products and not and this makes total
sense because calm well I'm a subscriber
to calm
they're Tories there they're pushing
asleep like crazy yeah sleep stories I
think was the breakout product for the
breakout feature for that's crazy and so
I didn't realize this until they like
point it out and I'm like oh yeah that
does make sense
sleep is way bigger than meditation and
meditation is huge sleep is also a lot
of people search for it because so for
meditation you're trying to teach a new
habit sleep everybody does also for
sleep a lot of you have problems
sleeping so they will actively search
for and pay for solutions that will help
them sleep I pay for a bunch of them I
pay for what's your sling an Alexa app
called nature sounds and they have like
26 sounds and I pay extra money to
combine them it's a lot my the one I
sleep two is winter railroad and so that
sound like it's a trick it's a train
going to the mountains in winter what's
the winter part what is the sound of
winter you hear like wid okay I love it
sure it's only very personal there I go
Alexa played nature sounds or sometimes
I'll do ship in winter because it sounds
like an ice breaker and then Alexa turn
off in 20 minutes nothing this is also
like one of these you know hackathon
projects or some developers like okay
watch this just say two words I go
search the internet for sounds and I
smash them together and it makes an
audio yeah for cons next hackathon they
should build this like I don't even know
what he could be like chickens and China
Street was a Sarah she doesn't like this
you like the sound with it so do you
take any sleep aids like like a like a
vitamin or supplement or CBD or
something melatonin melatonin yeah that
work helper yeah it does if I really
can't sleep I'll take one of those unit
to my computer to I think it died one of
my unit
you know gel is that what it's called
units off it's a it's basically like a
mild dosage of nyquil without the
medicine part oh that's good so okay so
it's the way some people take nyquil
just to sleep and so this is the just a
sleep part it just don't have a cough
yeah it's just a lite version you don't
take this stuff i I heard this phrase
today I could sleep in a ditch so I just
when I would
to go to sleep I instantly fall asleep
and I do not wake up at night ever
and so I'm blessed you know that I am
typically like that as well but not as
bad there's this guy that we should
profile he he he's a Japanese
billionaire or sorry Chinese billionaire
and he started a so he's a he's a big
shot now and he owns like half a bank
and all his other [__] and he got rich
by creating a melatonin
he just took melatonin and rebranded it
made it sexy and called it a sleep aid
and whatever it got huge and then he
launched the Zynga of China and he ended
up buying like the building that they
lived in just like Zynga and or they
worked in it became a huge thing we'll
have to do off to bring him up cuz I
love him because he's reckless and he's
built a fortune and lost it all like
three times right yeah you love that I
love those guys okay and then we also
talked about a Do It Yourself perfume so
apparently that's a huge community is Do
It Yourself perfume and there's not a
ton of companies in the space so what's
that what's happening what are these
people trying to do this okay do i buy
perfume they want to mix their own at
home yeah so basically perfume is a huge
business Paris Hilton a lot of people
forget about her she has sold roughly
five billion dollars of her perfume
cycling back to the porn conversation
earlier okay Paris Hilton yes yes and
let's say her stuff cost $100 which it
doesn't it it's typically ninety percent
margin yeah incredible so huge fat
margins and everyone now knows this and
so the idea here is that people are
trying to make their own perfume at home
and it's got there's a lot of sub sub
reddits around a lot of communities who
discuss different perfume like how to
create your own perfume but there aren't
too many companies that are making it
easy to make your own perfume and
formulas and things like that - that
makes a lot of sense this is like one of
those industries where when you hear
about the winner later you're like oh
okay was set up for success - for
example a Warby Parker you know one of
the reasons warburg Parker works so well
was that the existing eyewear eye glass
you know industry was all owned by this
one conglomerate Nautica that had price
pricing power and was marking [__] up
like crazy so they didn't have to like
invent something to lower the
they just had to not be greedy and be
like okay we can offer this at a fair
price and still have margin and so if
you own cologne I own Cologne and so
what you're saying is basically cologne
vastly marked up in the same way razors
or super marked up and Dollar Shave Club
came in but instead of somebody just
making a Dollar Shave Club version of
Cologne
they're giving you a DIY kit and there's
like probably reddit communities of home
brewers for perfume yeah it's actually
pretty great there's an infinite number
of recipes and scents so you're good
yeah is if you took it a step further an
interesting sense could be sold already
yeah so you could create a marketplace
where you could sell you yes you to just
even to your own friends and family you
could create a kit for people to do this
and make a better kit sure there's one
that exists well another idea you know
we're talking about kid stuff earlier
like my niece would love to mix her own
perfume she would that would be like a
great afternoon and my my sister would
buy her you know this little
kid-friendly perfume making kit it's
like one of the arts and crafts things
that she gets to do and she makes it an
Emeril who comes over she gets to show
him show her show them there yeah I
think you could do this for kids and be
a big deal here's another angle that we
found in trends is soap do-it-yourself
soap big thing people want to make their
own soap and what was the third one
juice but we already know that's right
juicing yeah it was pretty great I like
that I would have never known about that
that's pretty fascinating to me in fact
I'm gonna tell my sister to start this
business okay so yeah let's get let's
get into okay so a topic that we talked
about yesterday that you wanted me to
look into more was auctions auctions yes
I had never heard of this company that
you showed me heritage auctions yeah I
think that auctions particularly
marketplaces I would love someone to
criticize this because I want to hear
the downsides I think that they are
potentially one of the top like two or
three business models auctions or more
Oxford's and marketplaces all
marketplaces for sure yeah but action
style marketplaces I think there were
they're one of the bests yeah you've
seen a bunch of them yeah I think
they're a being the sort of classic yeah
and I think eBay sucks by the way
there's some ones totally gonna crush
them I mean they're gonna be dead not
dead
somebody told me this is half half half
information somebody told me eBay has
had like a revival and they don't do the
auction stuff as much anymore they're
all like it's basically Amazon is yeah
hate it I'm gonna hate it but if
somebody said that their numbers have
turned around I don't know faster well
they're a behemoth they're not going
anywhere anytime soon I mean they're
like Google like you're like oh well
they're sucking like okay I mean they're
gonna last for another 50 years at least
yeah
so anyway I love auctions I like I land
I love niche auctions and heritage which
you pointed out they do that you got the
you got that pulled up Henry and you
could pull it up on your phone so they
did 800 million dollars in sales so it's
not on the screen so let's look at the
top categories do you have it on your
phone yeah so coins I think was their
top right yeah so they do I think 300
million dollars in currency right okay
but look at some of the more interesting
ones movie posters 10 million 10 million
dollars in sales what was comics comics
is on there yeah and I just pull it up
what's it say for comics Henry comics 50
sports 60 million sport collectibles
basically mm-hmm luxury real estate 19
million wine 10 million crazy right tons
crazy and here's what I like about it
this is a big idea we talk a lot in fact
I have a pet peeve we talk a lot about
these like small little business
arbitrage is hacks little businesses
this would be a big big company if you
could get this right and so what so I
love I love marketplaces and I love
auctions I love auctions because there's
a time component to it yeah and that
urgency makes you buy more and what I
think is even better and so for heritage
auctions I think a roughly half of their
sales of a hundred million dollars sales
are online and the other half are in
person you want to know another
in-person auction that's doing
wonderfully barrett-jackson have you
heard of barrett-jackson know what it's
a barrett-jackson is based in Arizona
bootstrapped owned by one guy is that
his name Barret maybe Barry
Barrett is dead Jackson is alive okay or
it could be the other way around one of
them is dead but what they do is they
actually have a they put this on TV all
the time I watch it all the time what
they do is sell cars so classic cars
right not all classic cars but just like
rare or like interesting cars you could
buy like a $10,000 car there but so they
have a car on and they'll say like this
Ferrari there was only 500 of them this
it sells for $200 and they show it and
you're like oh awesome that sale just
happened in three minutes that was great
and so they do I believe 68 shows a year
and they make hundreds of millions of
dollars in revenue yeah it's a huge
business and I love that and so another
one is bring a trailer they do cars as
well and the guy who started bring a
trailer also started mailbox Gentry
Underwood so he's like a but she's sold
to Dropbox right and so I like these
auction places and first of all I like
niche auctions so I like watches
anything that's niche but tell but what
do you what is another and I have one an
idea idea what's a current marketplace
that's very ill liquid and hard to sell
and you wish I could go away faster
mm-hm houses luxury houses pay they put
on here because takes a while to sell a
house in general and so open doors
trying to make that instant as a market
but as a real estate company but not not
as much as an auction mm-hmm I have a
friend who did this with sneakers he
people are doing that now I think it's
working well he did it as a 90 minute
auction so he would say the sneaker goes
live it's 90 minutes and we're gonna get
you your guaranteed price or we they
basically offer the seller they're like
we will buy it at this price if the
auction doesn't go higher so if you
agree to that you start the process and
it's 90 minutes what else I don't know
what else you got small businesses okay
just flip my business and this is a
maybe would just fall flat this is one
of those it could be amazing or it would
just be horribly idea but if I were
quiet like brokerage who sponsors this
or if I were another brokerage I would
100% have an event and try to gather a
thousand people and we're gonna auction
off these businesses my idea from
yesterday the first dibs where you're
auctioning feature the future first
future first whatever you're going
create I think that would work really
well with this as well but business is
the hard part is you have there's so
many hard parts about it there's a lot
of hard price but one is just the
diligence right so like when I buy the
the movie poster or whatever if it has
sort of the certification and the the
person you know selling it sort of says
this is authentic
I don't need to look too much more into
it whereas with a business you really
have to sort of understand all these
different components I think that's hard
I agree it's hard but I think it's
interesting because like if someone just
like if I knew Shopify apps or something
and there's this gathering and they're
just auctioning off a [__] ton of them
and it's kind of like a storage war or
it's like which you're not sure what you
get it but let's just find out like it
could be fun to gamble tens of thousands
of dollars yeah just storage units that
would be interesting like a mystery box
basically [__] yeah that would be really
fun and and interesting is it have to be
cheap enough that's interesting someone
doing store a storage unit like blind
auctions yeah yeah surely they have to
be right I don't know but you could tie
some of these ideas together right so
like what HQ showed where they did
basically they took a traditional TV
show and turn it into a live streaming
mobile app where the game shows on on
your phone this is the future of TV like
you can do a QVC or I don't know what
show you talked about you watch the
auctions on but like well that's rare
jacket but there's another one called up
turn these into mobile live streamed
shows and you can essentially sell these
all through through you know you could
take so one way to look at it that's
what I was thinking about right so one
way to look at this is you you start
selling some item that's not currently
sold on these auction places might be
hard because a lot of time has passed
and sort of like you know the law of
supply demand has pulled things that
want to be sold this way into the market
but maybe you could find a new Tanish or
you just take the existing platforms and
you make them smaller more lightweight
and mobile focused you just win that way
and so like I don't know top hat er yeah
what do they double company its wish so
it's a mobile app where you see a bunch
of really cheap stuff from China random
stuff it could be like a back brace and
a ring and a you know whatever a poster
of dollars.you dollar store crap dollar
store well it's like the it's like the
wish crap which is like random
electronics and memorabilia laser
pointers yeah laser pointers and
rings and like you know whatever but
what they do is if it which is
interesting is it's a they sytem start
so you open up the app and you see all
these things in it like you've never
seen your adrenaline spike like this in
a mobile app before all the prices are
starting it like what are fifty dollars
and they just start dropping and then
somebody just hits buy and then they buy
it and so you kind of want to wait to
get it lower but you don't want to wait
to local somebody else is gonna buy it
so top Hatters a start-up here in San
Francisco and they do hundreds of
millions of dollars of revenue a very
good is a very interesting business I
don't know how profitable it is how
sticky it is blah blah blah but when you
go into the app it's like a it's like
being in like this high-stakes Chinese
but those dollar auctions like those
penny auctions things it's know that all
like [__] it like that but they but
you don't have to buy credits and stuff
like that it's more like wish but
instead of what they tap into is instead
of browsing and picking they pick they
like inject into your FOMO you know part
of your brain and so you're like okay
this item do I want it don't want it for
6 bucks 5 bucks 4 bucks 3 I'll take it
and you end up buying a whole bunch of
[__] and it's just a bunch of moms who
are bored at home that are just shopping
on this thing and they feel like hey
we're getting tons of value but like
this is stuff you didn't even know you
wanted you don't even want
it's just [__] it's just [__] and I'm
gonna download it and buy some stuff I
buy [__] all the time
how patter is cool we want to do one
more or end it there let's do one quick
one so I have this career advice so
there's this great line I think Sheryl
Sandberg said a while back which was if
you're offered a seat on a rocket ship
you don't ask which chair you just sit
down and buckle up something like that
that's her quote and I see people get
this wrong all the time and so you're
making let's say you're listening to
this and you're making career choices so
we talked a lot about businesses
business ideas but a lot of people who
are listening to this are not yet they
haven't you know they have a job and
they haven't yet you know started their
own company necessarily so when it comes
to job selection if you think about the
companies you're thinking about joining
I want you to classify them into cars
rocket ships or titanic's and basically
you got the goal in your career advice
is not to look at the role you know like
what is the job description say it's not
even really to look at the compensation
package although you know there should
be a minimum there but you want to
optimize for getting onto rocket ships
and so a rocket ship is a company that's
growing really really fast they've
figured out what they're doing and
there's still a whole bunch of problems
to be solved and they're the right type
of problems a bad problem is nobody
wants our product we had to figure out
how to get them to want it a good type
of problem is too many people want our
product we have to make sure we can keep
up with this demand and so you want to
you want to find a rocket ship and you
want to take whatever roles you can get
on that rocket ship you want to sit down
you want to buckle up because what ends
up happening in these fast-growing
companies is if you're good and you kill
it for even two months you'll get moved
and promoted to a better spot because
they'll be like oh this person can
actually do something we have so many
fires to put out okay we thought you
were a junior but like hey junior you're
now working on this thing because you're
the best we got and we I've seen you
problem-solve so far and so what a
mistake people make is they try to pick
a role that's a higher-ranking role
initially or better competition
initially but they join either a
slow-moving company where they're not
gonna learn it's not gonna grow or they
join a Titanic which is just you know
about to sink but hey I got the best
seat on the Titanic you don't want that
either and so my advice is find the
rocket ship companies take whatever seat
they'll give you crush it and then
they'll move you up great I think that
to add to the analogy a lot of people
shouldn't join that fast-growing thing
or do they want that fast-growing thing
but they want something that's mildly
growing is that what that car is yeah I
think that's that's where yeah I'm
speaking to the people that like someone
that they're trying to max out but
they're currently in the job track so if
you're trying to max out and you're not
starting your own business this is the
next best thing in my opinion yes like
not a lot some people a lot of you don't
want a maxim a you have kids and they're
like I want a nice life right I don't
want a high-risk high-reward life right
and to those people that advice doesn't
apply right and I'm just guessing a lot
of those people don't listen to the
podcast cuz if you're that person you
probably listen to like I don't know Bon
Jovi on your way to work you don't
listen to like a podcast about business
and ideas and all that stuff sure I
think we've self selected at least I
think that's good advice and by the way
when you have you got a job if you been
employed let's say not like kind of like
college-age but like since they
have you just done businesses of your
own uh we have like an acquisition and I
was kind of employed there but I but you
haven't gone and just interviewed for
jobs
I interviewed once a couple times and I
never got them what you interview for
for fungal for Jack Smith my best friend
I interviewed for his job and I didn't
get it they just didn't call me back I
started a bag Jack tell you the guy
who's like my best friend now I didn't
know him I interview his job oh you
didn't know him at the time I didn't
know I'm okay they interviewed me and
they didn't hire me and then two years
later we came best friends and you were
trying to be a salesperson or I don't
remember I think so
by the way I have a similar story I
applied to stripe I think I might have
told the story already so apology if I
did but 2012 I applied to I was gonna
apply for a job for the first time in my
life I'd started two companies before
that I was like I'm moving to Silicon
Valley I'm gonna get a job I'm gonna
learn from other people rather than
start my own thing and I only applied to
jobs
one was stripe and I got to the phone
screen and I really had it made because
the guy who was interviewing me
his mentor in life was one of my former
advisors in my startup and had written a
blog post being like this guy Sean is
like he said it specifically he has the
highest bias for action of any
entrepreneur I've ever met
he made a warm intro to this guy and was
like trust me this guy's legit you
should hire this kid [__] did you not
get that job and so I I thought I was
cruising too and maybe that's why I
didn't get it but I get to the part of
the interview where he was like all
right you know this job has a lot of
sort of sales and persuasion stuff so
you know we're peace software so I want
you to you know we're gonna do a little
roleplay you're gonna sell me a piece of
software and he's like you could pick
any software you like whatever you're
familiar with all you probably got
creative or something and I was just
like um I was like okay so I here's what
I would do I would talk to you about
this he said no no don't tell me what
you would do like I'm the customer hello
I just picked up the phone go and I was
like [__] and so I I was like hey you
know I'm telling you about
I picked Basecamp as my software big
mistake cuz I don't even know Basecamp
very well so I just like I just I didn't
call you back for that reason by the by
the end of that roleplay he was just
like yeah I don't think this is for you
I've just been on
with you like I just don't think you're
you know I'll wait for this that was
eight years ago
some yeah I was like probably 2023 year
24 at the time how [__] how early I'm
like I I blew it like it wasn't there
bad like I definitely blew that
interview how early of an employee would
you have been so I think they were at
like 50 maybe 50 people or less or less
you five million dollars well yeah I
don't know how much equity I would I
would have had to do the rocket ship
thing I would have had to start in a
crappy seat crush it and then get into a
good seat to get equity but like I did
that with uber and airbnb I had job
interviews at Airbnb and uber first 100
people and one of them I gotten one of
them I got the offer but then they
rescinded it cuz I lied about my resume
and the other one I didn't get past the
I had a criminal record and I told my
didn't they're like oh alright don't
come to work on Monday
dude that's hilarious at least you had
good eye for picking these companies and
then I applied at bungle and they sold
for 800 million dollars I always tell
people find out where I want to work at
who will also deny me and then invest
there okay let's start with where would
you want to work at today if you were
you back then where would you be
applying today
great question do you have an answer you
want to go for a couple years ago I
answer this I was like the only place I
would be really interested working with
his angel list at the time no I'd be
horrible at a place to work and so I
thought Angeles was doing really
interesting [__] and I think it's gonna
be begging it did end up becoming big
and this was like seven years ago so
this is a while ago ya know that would
be a horrible place to work though cuz
that like all guys [__] crazy really
I don't know but he seems like a
brilliant genius so a great person
listened to but a horrible person to
manage you if okay if I had to work
somewhere I probably hmm probably just
somewhere with really good managers most
startups have horrible managers and it's
like when you were looking at uber
Airbnb you didn't know the managers so
you weren't using that criteria van no
but and I don't know if it would've been
successful Sara my wife works at Airbnb
and she loves her managers and you know
how everyone's like so what are you
gonna do next they always say that and
she's like what do you mean by whatever
do anything next is awesome would be for
a really long time
and I would love to have that feeling I
would probably now look for a company
that's I would go find all the most
interesting biotech based companies so
anybody doing something with genetics
genomics modification anything like that
I think that's a big wave that's coming
I do try to be early they're
self-driving cars if there's someone
who's awesome there I'd do something
than that if or it's hard though it's
really hard if I wanted to make a lot of
money let's say I wanted to like bigger
I'm gonna try and save hundreds of
thousands of dollars in the next three
years of work I work at Facebook or what
well Facebook Google or an enterprise
sales role at a super boring b2b me
enterprise software company right where
the where the average deal is like three
or four hundred thousand dollars a year
right that's what I would do so if I
took my own advice I would look for
who's a rocket ship so I would try to
maybe like lambda school I think it's
interesting I would just basically try
to go fine who's the fastest growing
startup right now that's at maybe 50
people or 20 people or what are the 10
people whatever they are I would go try
to find them and then I would be like
hey I'll come solve any problems you got
like we'll figure it out I went to the
sub stack office the other day they just
raised sixteen million dollars in
funding you know how many employees they
have five five I would that would be an
interesting place to work okay who does
better in the long term only fans or sub
stack okay so for creating the owner's
wealth only fans for creating a valuable
company that could potentially sell for
more sub stack by far so take both paths
right sub types can either have to sell
or go public and only fans Ohio might
just you know spit off cash if I had
were so where would I work know which
business do you think Nets more more
money in the end which business
exploding pants because the likelihood
that sub-sect is gonna succeed is low
very low what if they do it right I
think it could be really big yeah I was
talking to that guy Hamish I think he
came to here the other day okay cool I
was trying to get him on this podcast I
mean I already asked him he said no yeah
he was like oh you know my first million
I don't want to definitely told me to do
it yeah I was like
you're overthinking this dude you're
just doing interesting things we just
want to talk about your [__] in front of
munch people who are interested and he
was like overthinking it a little bit
nice guy but I went and met with him and
their old co the CEO we could probably
get him on there just engineering dorks
they're cool right and then I think
they're gonna have the same problem
patreon has which is kind of an awesome
product that supports a lot of people
and people have it's a really valuable
tool but they're taking a very small cut
of a very small amount of money yeah and
so what I'm trying to do is tell them to
pivot and like guys will pay you a [__]
ton of money if you create paywalls for
bigger companies right
they're not gonna pivot they've raised
their money and they they have their
dream we're a few meetings in we'll see
yeah I think it's a 10% chance all right
that's pretty good okay cool we got
anything else or nope
we're cool we'll end it now all right
thank you for listening